قال مدير مستشفى برزيالي الاسرائيلي في
عسقلان البروفيسور حيزي ليبي ان اكثر من
3500 جريح عولجوا منذ السابع من اكتوبر
تشرين الاول الماضي في المستشفى واضاف
ليفي ان هذا الرقم لم يشهده لا هو ولا
اكثر الاطباء تمرسا من قبل مشيرا الى ان
الصعوبه لا تكمن في تدفق المصابين على
المستشفى بل في العدد الكبير للحالات التي
نقلت اليه للعلاج في يوم
واحد افادت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
تقديرات الجيش تشير الى ان الحرب لن تنجح
في خفض اطلاق الصواريخ من قطاع غزه نحو
اسرائيل الى الصفر ونقلت الاذاعه المذكوره
عن مسؤولين في الجيش ان تكثيف القتال
الميداني يساهم في الحد من القدرات
الصاروخيه في
غزه
معنا الان من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك سياده العقيد اذا لنبدا
من هذا الخبر الذي اوردناه للتو عن توقعات
اسرائيليه بان هذه الحرب لن تنجح في تخفيض
قدرات حماس على اطلاق الصواريخ للصفر ما
الذي يعنيه ذلك ما دلاله الاعلان عن هذا
الخبر نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه الجزير
اهلا بك نعم لا شك بانه اثبتت الفتره
الماضيه منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه بعد 7
اكتوبر والى يومنا هذا مع انطلاق العمليه
البريه بان هذه العمليه لم تحد من القدرات
العسكريه لفصائل المقاومه بما فيها كتاب
عز الدين القسام وبذلك استطاعت المقاومه
خلال هذه الفتره ان تصل الى اهداف مهمه في
عمق الاراضي المحتله وهذا دليل واضح
على ان هناك خطه استراتيجيه قد وضعت
لاستمرار هذه الصواريخ بالانطلاق سواء في
مناطق محيطه غزه او في المناطق التي تشكل
عمق ومركز ثقل استراتيجي وخاصه العاصمه
تلبيب وبالتالي نرى بان الفتره الماضيه
شهدت ضربات متعدده للفصائل باتجاه هذه
الاهداف وانا اعتقد بانها ستستمر لانه
البنيه وطبيعه الارض ووجود الانفاق يساعد
بشكل كبير جدا المقاومه على استمرار بمثل
هذه العمليات لذلك نقول بانها فشلت لحد
هذه اللحظه من الحد على الرغم من
الامكانيات والقدرات العسكريه الكبيره
التي يتمتع بها الجيش الصهيوني وخاصه
الطائرات المسيره التي لا تغيب عن سماء
غزه ابدا والتي تقوم بتصوير كل شيء
بالاضافه الى الاقمار الصناعيه بالاضافه
الى الدول التي قدمت الكثير من المساعده
بما فيها بريطانيا بارسال طائره الاستطلاع
والتجسس بالاضافه الى ما تقدمه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من مع معلومات
استخباراتيه ولكن لحد هذه اللحظه لم تستطع
ان توقف
الصواريخ باتجاه عمق الاراضي المحتله او
في منطقه غلاف غز حتى يعني ونحن نتحدث
يعني الاخبار دائما تتوالى عن اصابات و
للدبابات وناقلات جند وفي الوقت نفسه نسمع
نتنياهو يقول
انه يحتاج لمزيد من الوقت وان الحرب
ستستمر اشهر
فعليا هل يستطيع الجيش الاسرائيلي الصمود
اشهر في في ظل هذه الخسارات التي او
الخسائر التي يمنى
بها نعم بدايه دعيني اقول بان اداء
المقاومه بدا يتطور ويتصاعد بصوره مذهله
خاصه في الاسابيع الاخيره اذا ما اردنا ان
نقارن بدايه العمليات العسكريه لفصائل
المقاومه مع العمليات التي تحدث في الفت
الره الاخيره نجد بان هناك خبره تراكميه
خلال هذه الفتره استفادت منها فصائل
المقاومه في توظيف عملياتها العسكريه ولكن
الاصرار الصهيوني ياتي من قبل نتنياهو
لاسباب سياسيه لان هو يعرف جيدا بان عمليه
وقف الحرب او الذهاب الى الى التفاوض قد
يؤدي الى انهاء مستقبله السياسي علما بانه
سوف يحال الى المسائله القانونيه يضاف الى
ذلك بان هناك خلافات سياسيه وعسكريه تعصف
الان بالحكومه بحكومه نتنياهو وهذا هو احد
الاسباب الذي يؤدي الى الاستمرار بهذه
العمليه العسكريه على الرغم من تقديم
الاستشارات من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بانه يجب انهاء هذه الحرب
والانتقال الى مرحله ثالثه ورغم الاستشاره
التي تقدم له من بعض العسكريين القدامى
الذين كانوا بمناصب متقدمه كوزير دفاع او
رئيس اركان ولكن الاصرار الذي ياتي من قبل
حكومه نتنياهو هو لاسباب انها تتعلق بال
المستقبل السياسي وتتعلق بمصالح شخصيه ليس
ال ولكن هل يصمد هذا الاصرار بدون دعم
امريكي وامداد بالسلاح يعني الان قبل قليل
ورد خبر عن نقلا عن الواشنطن بوست عن
السنتر الديمقراطي كريس هولين يقول تتجاوز
اداره بايدن الكونجرس لبيع اسلحه لاسرائيل
هذا التجاوز يقوض الشفافيه عندما تعلو
اصوات مثل هذا هذه في
الكونجرس ربما تدفع بايدن في النهايه الى
قطع خط الامداد الذي يعتمد عليه نتنياهو
بالاساس كيف سيؤثر هذا على
الموقف نعم لا شك ان هذا هو عامل مؤثر
بشكل كبير لانه الان بدات الاصوات تتعالى
على اداره بايدن بانه اخفق هو ومستشار
الامن القومي ووزير الخارجيه في السياسه
الخارجيه خصوصا باتجاه قضيه اوكرانيا
والان باتجاه قضيه الحرب في غزه هناك الان
ضغوطات كبيره تمارس على حكومه بايدن في
هذا الاتجاه بما فيها مساله الدعم المفتوح
الذي يقدم لحكومه نتنياهو والتي تستخدم في
قتل المدنيين وتدمير الممتلكات العامه
والخاصه والبنى التحتيه نعم هذه الحرب هي
تخضع لتحديات كثيره من ضمن هذه التحديات
بالنسبه لحكومه نتنياهو هو العامل
الاقتصادي والدعم الخارجي والخسائر التي
تضغط بشكل كبير جدا يضاف الى ذلك مساله
الاسرى المتواجدين لدى قياده فصائل
المقاومه جميع هذه النقاط هي عوامل ض غ طه
على حكومه نتنياهو في مساله الوقوف يعني
عند حد معين لانه العسكريين يرون بانه لا
توجد اهداف عسكريه الان لكي يتم تنفيذها
في داخل قطاع غزه خصوصا وانها توغلت في
الفتره الماضيه في القطاع الشمالي وبدات
بالانسحاب من هذه المناطق والان هي تحاول
ان تتوغل في مناطق ولكن هذا التوغل له
كلفه باهظه هذهه الكلفه لا شك بانها ستؤدي
الى خسائر والمشكله بان الجيش غير قادر
على ان يحقق او ينجز شيء على الارض لكي
يقد يمه كانجا حقيقي بالنسبه للاهداف التي
وضعت من قبل حكومه نتنياهو لذلك هناك
اشكال كبير جدا الان في مساله الاستمرار
بالعمليه العسكريه وهناك ضغوطات امريكيه
تقول بانه يجب ان ننتهي من هذا الامر وقد
قدمت بالفتره الماضيه طلبات على على
طائرات اباتشي وقد رفض هذا الامر وقدمت
ايضا طلبات
لاستيراد
قذائف للدبابات 45000 لم يوافقوا الا على
14000 منها هناك الان تقديم ايضا على
مدفعيه 155 وجرت الموافقه ولكن اعتقد بان
هذه الموافقه مشروطه وهناك انتقادات بانها
يمكن ان يتاخر ارسالها الى الى الكيان
الصهيوني جميع هذه الامور هي عوامل ضاغطه
ويجب على حكومه نتنياهو ان تقوم باجراء
حقيقي لانهاء هذه الماساه الموجوده في
شمال في في قطاع غزه اشكرك العقيد الركن
حاتم كريم الفلاحي كنت معنا من اسطنبول
شكرا